now we also want to let you know there
is a Statewide teacher shortage and an
area feeling the hardest hit is Clark
County but lawmakers are of course
trying to address that they've
introduced a measure and funds to make
it easier for teachers to get licensed
Joshua baguero tells us more
Brandon Summers is a substitute teacher
in Clark County he knows one thing you
can do to attract more folks to the
teaching profession I think every state
and every every school district needs to
work on increasing pay so that they can
attract teachers to work for the
districts with several education related
bills making their way through the
legislature Summers says teachers are
stretching themselves thin due to
vacancies the short staffing makes it
hard for you to just be able to do your
job and go home a lot of times you have
to take on other responsibilities it
takes time away from the classroom when
you could be doing lesson planning three
bills went before the Senate education
committee Wednesday one is Senate Bill
438 it seeks to address the high number
of teacher vacancies by creating a
program called Teach Nevada scholarship
that would set aside 50 million dollars
in scholarships Nevada is averaging
nearly 2 800 teacher job openings and in
Clark County alone there are more than
1400 vacancies Miranda Garcia is a
student at UNLV studying to become a
teacher at CCSD I struggled a lot in
school and I wouldn't have made it
without my teachers and I want to be
able to help students that struggle like
me this graphic shows the highest
concentration of teacher openings in
Clark County they are in parts of the
valley where the majority student
populations are Black and Hispanic
Garcia waiting to testify in support of
SB 438 says she's thankful for a state
scholarship she received that will
hopefully get her in a CCSD classroom
soon the scholarship is amazing it helps
me
for like my classes but my textbook s
Joshua peguero eight news now